hey youtubers is Charlie so even more
stuff from thor ragnarok from the set we
finally found out where odin is so
there's going to be a breakdown of that
as well as Odin versus Thanos and the
other forces of Ragnarok a lot of you
will recognize this is kind of a fun
twist on what happened in the first Thor
movie where Odin Dean Thor unworthy for
being a douchebag took his hammer ladies
and Chapman on it you know let you
whoever be worthy and then banished him
to earth without any of his abilities I
mean obviously his physiology is a lot
tougher than a normal humans but he
didn't have his gear didn't have his
hammer so we couldn't fly so the real
question here is is obviously like Loki
in HeLa or somebody else has teamed up
to banish Odin to earth but does he know
that he's Odin like Thor knew that he
was Thor when he was walking around but
if Odin knows that he's Odin is he
somehow blocked from his power it
doesn't look like he has his spear
so maybe Loki and HeLa have done
something to his memories but it just
looks like he's been on the street
living homeless since the last movie so
no idea when we encounter him I would I
would expect that he's going to be
sidelined for most of the movie because
what kind of a threat is the villain if
one of the most powerful beings in the
universe is on hand with his full
strength
so if Odin was around there wouldn't be
as much of a movie so part of the fun of
the movie is trying to fix everything
without Odin's help and something might
happen to Heimdall too because he's also
one of the most powerful people in
Asgard and it sounds like the writers
don't want Thor to have that crutch to
lean on although the funny thing is is
when we were looking at the behind the
scenes stuff with Loki and Thor getting
ready to meet Doctor Strange
it looks like Loki puts an enchantment
on them to change their appearance so
the umbrella that Thor is walking around
that stick might be his hammer
so maybe Odin is walking around with his
spear but he doesn't know it because he
doesn't have his memories I would just
expect when we see Odin walking around
like shuffling around looking through
the garbage for something to eat we see
a bunch of Ravens nearby there'll be a
lot of Odin like things a lot of winks
at who he really is
but you could imagine like a really
grumpy version of Odin grumpier than
normal he's already a grumpy person so
imagine an extra grumpy version just
shuffling through your garbage looking
for food but the real twist is when he
finally comes back because you know the
idea of the movie is Ragnarok
which is basically the death and rebirth
of the
universe so if something that big is
going to happen I would bet that he's
going to come back just in time for like
the big WTF fight with all of the
Ragnarok monsters like you have the
Midgard serpent you have fire Lord sir
you have Fenris well you have like all
these amazing huge crazy monsters so it
makes sense that Onan would be around
for a big fight like that so I would
expect that whenever that happens he'll
appear and he will just rain down the
odinforce on all of them so the other
question is danos he's one of the other
most powerful beings in the universe
like you have Odin he's super powerful
they're gonna sideline him I would bet
they also try to use Thanos relatively
sparingly because when you bring him
into the story and you have Odin - it's
just like well how come they don't just
go at each other well you know mostly
that would kill the story and it would
leave out the fun of him coming after
Loki trying to get the gems learning
their location so it is a safe bet that
there's going to be a lot of people in
this movie that are flip-flopping sides
and even though it's really crazy
there'll be a lot of humor with that -
like even when Loki is being really evil
he can still be really funny so at some
point he will have to join Thor and help
him out and presumably that'll be after
all of the other villains in the movie
turn on him like after Thanos turns on
after HeLa turns on him because she's
also one of the most powerful beings in
the universe one of the few people who
could actually go up against Odin so
there's no way that Loki would be able
to sideline Odin without her help but
let me know in the comments when do you
think that Odin is going to come back in
the movie and which Ragnarok monsters do
you think that we'll see we already know
that fire Lords Serdar and Fenris wolf
are going to be in the movie they might
have some more those just the big ones
that were in the teaser at Comic Con but
for those of you asking about Thanos vs
Odin in the classic version of warlock
and the infinity watch like during that
title they actually fought Odin handed
him his ass so under normal
circumstances
Thanos without the Infinity Gauntlet
will get stomped by Odin but the whole
idea of the movies is that he's
assembling the gauntlet so after he does
assemble it then all bets are off so you
can see why they have to side light Odin
for most of the movie because if he
could stomp Thanos on a normal day then
there's no story like you don't have a
movie so we haven't had any confirmation
of Anthony Hopkins being in an infinity
war they will address the
idea of Odin I mean they'll have to
especially at the end of thor ragnarok
like what's going to happen with his
character going forward is he going to
pass his power to Thor what the hell's
going on so let me know in the comments
do you think that Odin will show up
during infinity war but even if he's not
he is definitely going to have his blaze
of glory moment during Ragnarok so if
you guys didn't see I just posted the
Captain America Civil War bloopers I
announced like the giveaway has been
upgraded big time upgrade so
congratulations to the first winner
Daniel 97 you win an Amazon gift card
for the value of the blu-ray which is I
think it's about $30 right now so please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details and I'll go ahead and restart
the giveaway so all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video there'll be plenty more
Marvel DC this weekend there's some cool
Game of Thrones stuff that just drops so
I'll probably be doing a video for that
tomorrow so get hype while you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to
watch the Civil War bloopers again and
you can click here to learn about how
Captain America isn't going to be
Captain America in the movies anymore
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight